ليه نبدا مع احمد هزيم من واشنطن والموقف
الامريكي همم اذا هذا التطور والحدث
اللافث في بولندا
حسن ما استمعناه حتى اللحظه من تصريحات
المسؤول الامريكيين سواء في اي احاطتي
وزاره الخارجيه ووزاره الدفاع او حتى ما
تحدثت به المندوبه الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده
والمتحدثه ايضا باسم مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي كل الحديث يدور على ان الولايات
المتحده على علم بهذا التقاء بهذا بهذه
التقارير هناك تريث في اتخاذ موقف من ما
حدث هناك في على على الحدود البولنديه
الاوكرانيه همم اغتصاب جاري بين بين
المسؤولين الامريكيين والمدراهم في بولندا
كان هناك اتصال بين مستشار الرئيس الامن
القومي جاكسون مع نظيره هناك في هولندا
ليست
مزيد من المعلومات واستطاع عن طبيعه هذا
الهجوم مع التاكيد دائما بان هناك تعهد
كان اطلقه الرئيس الامريكي
بدايه الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا من
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بتفعيل البند
الخامس والدفاع عن كل شبر من الاراضي همم
دول في شمال الاطلسي مع الاخذ في الاعتبار
كما قال المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه فدان
قتال من ان الولايات المتحده
خيارات عده للتعاطي مع روسيا في حال اذا
كانت روسيا هي من اطلق هذه الصواريخ على
هذه البلده او القريه البولنديه بالنسبه
للولايات المتحده حسن الحساب هنا حساب
معقد للغايه هناك تعهد امريكي صريح وواضح
وتم التاكيل عليه اليوم في حاله البنتاجون
وحتى في احاطه وزاره الخارجيه من الولايات
المتحده ستدافع عن كل شبر من اراضي دول
حلف شمال الاطلسي وهناك المساله الثانيه
وهي المخاطره بدي بالدخول في صراع مسلح
كبير قد يكون بمثابه حرب عالميه الثالثه
في حاله اصطدام مباشر بين حلف شمال
الاطلسي في خيانه الولايات المتحده وبين
القوات الروسيه فالتعاطي الامريكيه الحذر
من الانزلاق وراء هذه التقارير والبلقاء
بتريث للاستطاع اا معلومات اكثر من الجانب
البولندي هو لعدم انزلاق هذا هذه الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا الى حرب عالميه
ثالثه او مواجهه مباشره بين روسيا ودول
حلف شمال الاطلسي وما كانت الولايات
المتحده تعبر عنه دائما بانها لا تسعى الى
هذه المواجهه وعبرت عنه اليوم ايضا في
احاطه وزاره الخارجيه بان واشنطن لا تزال
تحاول استبعاد اي احتمال الدخول في مواجهه
مباشره مع الجانب الروسي ربما الرد الروسي
او تصريحات روسيه النافيه همم تصعب من
اتخاذ الموقف الامريكي او اتخاذ الولايات
المتحده لاي موقف ما يتعلق في بولندا
خصوصا وان اثبت بولندا ان لديها من
المعلومات ومن المعطيات ما يجعلها متيقنه
من ان هذه الصواريخ روسيه وليست صواريخ
كما بعد اشاره بعض التقارير الاعلاميه
الروسيه صواريخ اوكرانيه وقعت بالخطا
المتحدثه او المندوبه الامريكيه لدى الامم
المتحده ايضا تحدثت من هناك مسار سيدخل في
الامم المتحده في حال تم الحصول على مزيد
من المعلومات تؤكد من ان هذه الصواريخ
التي استهدفت هذه القريه البولنديه هي
صواريخ حتى الان الجانب الروسي مازال
ينفي ان يكون قد استهدف همم
الاراضي البولنديه او ايه اهداف خارج
اوكرانيا لكن همم كياذ على ما يبدو ااه
تصعد الموقف بشكل كبير كيف بدا هذا الموقف
في اعقابي ما حصل في بولندا المعتز بالله
حسن
بالتاكيد راى الاوكرانيون ووفقا تصريحات
الورده على لسان المسؤولين هنا ان هذا
التطور هو ما حذر منه سابقا الرئيس
الاوكراني كان تحدث قبل قليل وقال انه ما
تحدثت به اوكرانيا وما حدثت
منه عبر الشهور الماضيه ها نحن نراه على
ارض الواقع صواريخ تقع على اراضي اوروبا
وبالتالي هذه اول
وبالتالي التهديدات الروسيه هي لم تقتصر
على المساحه الاوكرانيه فقط وانما هي تمتد
دول النيه وهذا التصريح الرئيس الاوكراني
ايضا وزير الخارجيه الاخراني في نفس
السياق وزير رئيس الوزراء الاوكراني ايضا
وزير الدفاع كلها هؤلاء تحدث عن هذه
القضيه ومن انها تطور خطير في مجرى
الاحداث وان روسيا بحسب الاوكرانيين هي
ماضيه في تهديداتها وانه حان الوقت للوقوف
في وجه بوتين لايقافه عن هذه الحرب التي
يشنها على اوكرانيا يرى الاوكرانيون ان
هذه فرصه لزياده الدعم بالنسبه لهم خصوصا
وانهم يقولون انهم جاهزون للدفاع عن حلف
الناتو في جناحه الشرقي تصريح وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني قبل قليل تناول هذه
النقطه وايضا التاكيد على ان اوكرانيا هي
الماضيه في استعاده كافه اراضيها دعنا
نذكر حسن ان اليوم اوكرانيا تعرضت لهجمه
صاروخيه كبيره تعتبر كبيره اكثر من 100
صاروخ بحسب المسؤولين الاوكرانيين هذه
الصواريخ تم اسقاطه معظمها ولكن هناك
صواريخ ضربت همم
قطاع الطاقه في اوكرانيا هناك جزء من
العاصمه كيف الجزء الاكبر من العاصمه كيف
هو يعاني الان من هذا الامر وايضا عدد من
المدن الى الاوكرانيه وبالتالي هذه الضربه
همم يقول الاوكرانيون انها تزامنت مع قمه
العشرين وبالتالي هي وجهه صفحه لقمه
المصريين وكل همم من تحدث عن ضروره وجود
روسيا في هذه القمه الاوكرانيون كانوا
تحدثوا سابقا عن ضروره عدم وجود روسيا في
هذه القمه وبالتالي الاوكرانيون ينظرون
الى هذه الحادثه حادثه سقوط همم الصواريخ
على الاراضي البولنديه على انها تصديق
لرواياتهم التي دائما ما يقولونها او
النظريه التي يدافعون عنها بان التهديدات
الروسيه هي لا تقف عند حدوده اوكرانيا بل
هي مستمره الى دول
اتقنعنا همم المعتز